it's great to be joined today by Liz
Watson who's the Democratic nominee
running for the US House of
Representatives in Indiana's ninth
congressional district against the
incumbent Republican Trey Hollingsworth
very interesting race in an interesting
part of the country Liz it's so great
for you to join us today it's great to
be here thanks for having me so for
people in our audience who may be
congregated in coastal cities tell us a
little bit about sort of what are the
key issues in in your particular
district sure so first let me just
situate where Indiana's ninth is so I'm
from Bloomington Indiana which is a Big
Ten University Town Indiana University
home to more than 50,000 students and
the 9th district spans all the way from
the Indianapolis suburbs down to the
Kentucky border so it's very long it's
about two hours 45 minutes driving the
speed limit top to bottom and some of
the really big issues in this district
that we're facing are not being able to
afford to fill prescriptions a terrible
opioid crisis that is really swept
across our district and ravaged families
and caused a lot of families to be torn
apart children are being raised by
grandparents because their parents can't
raise them because they're in the grips
of substance abuse a lot of folks who
can't afford the treatment they need to
get better living wage jobs are a big
issue in this district we've had a lot
of deindustrialization factories that
have shut down making sure that the jobs
that people have allow them to earn a
living wage and raise their families in
with dignity is important to folks in
this district protecting the
institutions that built the middle class
like Medicare and Social Security very
important people in this district making
sure that our public schools are strong
these are the bread-and-butter issues
that keep folks up at night this is a
state that has leaned very far into the
voucher movement that Betsy DeVos has
championed and so our public schools are
under attack as our taxpayer dollars are
siphoned out to private schools through
vouchers so a few of those issues you
mentioned sort of relate to
health care so maybe we could we could
talk about that a little bit you support
HR 676 the expanded improved Medicare
for all Act of 2017
even though I'm sure as you know and
much of my audience knows and and I
understand the idea is that even though
such a program would have costs that
overall it would decrease the total cost
not only to the individual but also to
the government as a recent report showed
that being said I'm guessing that in
particularly or inclusively of states
like yours talking about an additional
tax is not necessarily the most popular
thing so can you talk a little bit about
sort of how you communicate that even
though yes there will be some cost for
Medicare for all the savings will exceed
that cost how do you talk about that
with people who may have sort of an
anti-tax
perspective in general well I will say I
think what's important to remember here
is that we can walk and chew gum we can
shoot for this big vision which is
Medicare for all which is really where
we need to go and we can also protect
the Affordable Care Act which Trey
Hollingsworth voted my opponent voted to
repeal at the same time we can do both
of those things so things like being
able to negotiate prescription drug
prices under Medicare just like the VA
does are very important to folks in this
district we still have 48 thousand
people who are uninsured in our district
being able to insure those who don't
have insurance is so important and not
going back to the bad old days when
folks with pre-existing conditions
couldn't get healthcare which is what my
opponent wants to do so you know the
stories of folks in this district are
really just heartbreaking I over the
weekend was in Jeffersonville and talked
to a woman who I met about maybe six
months ago in Harrison County and she
told me about how she was actually a
lifelong Republican but her sister got
sick and her sister had
a lot of very serious conditions and she
went to the hospital and tried to get
treatment and they found out she didn't
have insurance and they sent her home
the next day with a bottle of aspirin
and when she was I don't I don't mean to
interrupt but only because we we don't
have an unlimited amount of time I
certainly understand everything you're
saying but my question was more about
under Bernie's medicare-for-all plan
which again you you support he's talking
about two point something percent income
tax on employees and nearly seven
percent on employers I think that that's
okay because there would be so much
savings on the back end in terms of
insurance premiums co-pays and
coinsurance but my question was more how
do you talk to red Staters about that
without the anti-tax reaction yeah I
talked about the fact that Medicare is
one of the most popular programs we've
ever had we know that when people hit 65
years old they see an improvement in
their health outcomes even though you
know in general as you get older health
outcomes decline and that's because all
of a sudden people have access to health
care imagine if we all had that
throughout our life all of the
preventive maintenance that could be
done we know actually the Koch brothers
just funded a study that was put out
which basically said yes there are
savings associated with Medicare all
they didn't intend that to be be outcome
but it was the outcome of the study
because it's true you know when you cut
out all the haggling with health
insurance companies when you allow for
the negotiation of drug prices when you
put all of this together right you
actually have a savings in the aggregate
and and that's what Medicare for all
would do so you know when we talk about
when we talk about costs it's it's
really important to talk about the ways
in which Medicare is actually going to
bring down costs and allowing folks to
use this very successful program which
has it's not perfect and should be
improved but which has held costs down
over time will be a significant
improvement and cost savings which the
Koch brothers study just confirmed so
the other thing to think about you know
my opponent voted for the tax law right
the tax law that blew a 1.5 trillion
dollar hole in our deficit and he's
going to result in millions of people
going without insurance over
the next decade and he did that actually
to give a 4.5 million dollar tax cut to
himself and similar giant tax cuts to
the 1% and giant corporations so if you
want to talk about fiscal
irresponsibility then the poster child
of that is Trey Hollingsworth my
opponent he's incredibly irresponsible
in saying I you know he's a guy with the
58 million dollar net worth he voted to
give himself a 4.5 million dollar tax
cut which happened to be the exact same
amount he and his dad spent to buy his
seat in Congress so you know he now has
broken even and he's made it possible
for his billionaire class friends to buy
another yacht I think actually a better
way to spend taxpayer dollars is on the
American public is on bringing down
health care costs is on investing in our
infrastructure is on our public schools
I don't think that more tax cuts for the
mega-rich is the right approach and in
fact I think that is just fiscal
irresponsibility at its height I'm
really interested in the topic of gun
rights and gun safety particularly in
the Midwest over the weekend I was at
Netroots nation in New Orleans Louisiana
and I spoke to JD Schulten who's running
as a Democrat in Iowa I spoke to
congressman Tim Ryan who is currently a
congressman in in Ohio and we talked
about the sort of need to in some cases
tread kind of lightly in certain parts
of the country including the Midwest
when running as a Democrat on the issue
of gun safety I noticed that on your
website you do list gun safety slash gun
rights sort of far down I think it was
like somewhere between 12th and 15th on
a list of about 15 different topics can
you talk a little bit about how you sort
of deal with that issue given the part
of the country you're running in though
I'm from my opponent is actually not
from Indiana so I don't think he's as
familiar with our gun culture here in
Indiana I am in from Bloomington it's
where I grew up we had two guns in my
house growing up and so I am a strong
supporter of Second Amendment rights and
I believe you can support Second
Amendment rights and you can also keep
our kids and communities safe we can
we can do both we're smart enough to
figure that out so you know hunting is
very important around here in a lot of
our rural communities the nearest police
station isn't close I talked to a friend
of mine who told me about you know
sometimes when she's going out to her
house late at night she likes to have a
gun with her because it's miles and
miles from anybody else and she's the
only person around so you know this is
this is rural Indiana and we certainly
want to protect people's right to own
guns and we also want to keep our kids
safe and I have two kids I put on a
school bus every day actually today is
their back to school this afternoon
they're going to meet their teachers and
they go to my elementary school where I
went growing up and I want to know that
my two kids are going to come home on
the bus to meet and be safe every single
day that's exactly what every mom and
dad across southern Indiana wants and
it's what every Grandma and Grandpa
wants and we're gonna make that happen
so as far as specific policies that that
you would include in finding that
balance would you support do you support
100% universal background checks for all
gun sales regardless of where those gun
sales are taking place of course I do
and you know NRA members support
background checks this is a universally
supported almost universally supported
proposal it just makes sense to be able
to do a background check on someone
before they get a gun and that's
something that I strongly support along
with the vast majority of a catkins yeah
and then how about as far as
restrictions on particular types of
firearms that one maybe should not be
able to buy so I mean I can go through
the full range of things that I support
for you things like raising the age to
buy a weapon waiting periods in terms of
looking at particular weapons that
people might buy we do know that most of
the mass shootings that have occurred
have been have used assault weapons
they've used particular kinds of weapons
and that these are weapons that are very
effective for gunning down a whole lot
of people really fast and so we need to
be very careful
about about that and and we know that
during the period in which the assault
weapons ban was in place and reminder it
was in place for a decade we saw a
decline in mass shootings so before the
before the ban went into place there
were many more mass shootings during the
period it was in place there were a lot
fewer and then when the ban was lifted
there were a lot more so that's some
pretty strong evidence that that ban was
effective now the way that it's
currently written the legislation that's
pending in Congress it grandfather's in
whatever folks existing weapons people
already have so it's talking about newly
manufactured weapons and so we want to
make sure and and that's something we
need to look at right maybe the language
in the current legislation isn't perfect
maybe there are more guns that people
need to use and want to use for hunting
etc that ought to be off that list I
that's something I have been in a lot of
conversations with gun owners about and
the way that I go about having these
conversations you know a lot of my
supporters are gun owners a lot of my
supporters are hunters I say what do you
think you know and that's the
conversation to be having right it's to
listen to the experts how do we keep our
kids safe and protect our way of life at
the same time and let's just to make
sure I understand only because you you
said a lot of interesting things there
it does that mean that from where we are
right now going forward you would be
interested in expanding or shrinking the
list of firearms that can be legally
purchased I'd be interested in sitting
down with gun owners to really
understand which of these are very
important to you know to hunting to
write and and and having that
conversation right that would be I think
useful and important so you so ok wow
that's interesting so so if the case was
a compelling case that there were for
example banned assault weapons that
hunters say they want to use that that
might be something you'd consider so I
support the assault weapons ban it does
list a whole lot of weapons I think that
you know anybody who's diligent in the
in signing on to legislation I would
want to go through and understand every
single thing that's on that list and
what its what its purpose is what it's
mainly used for
etc and make sure that that I'm making a
very informed decision that's a good
approach if only more people actually
read what they were what they were
signing I think that that would be it's
it's refreshing to hear that that's
something you would do we've been
speaking with Liz Watson who's the
Democratic nominee running for the US
House of Representatives in Indiana's
ninth congressional district which as
I'm sure our audience can tell is a
unique place to be running as a Democrat
as I think where our conversation has
illuminated Liz I really appreciate you
taking time to talk to me and a good
good luck in your race against the
incumbent Republican Trey Hollingsworth
well thank you I appreciate your time